what exactly is caching to simplify it
in one sentence caching is a mechanism
using which we decrease the amount of
time and effort it takes to perform some
amount of work that is the on line
explanation of what exactly is caching
and a more technical definition of that
would be caching is basically keeping a
subset of some data let's say we have a
primary data and when we keep a subset
not the whole data a subset of that data
depending on the uses of the data the
frequency of the uses and the
probability of the next uses time etc
etc depending on a lot of parameters
when you keep a subset of some data in a
location which is faster to access which
takes less time and also it is easier
which means it is it also takes less
effort so technically speaking caching
is a mechanism using which we can
decrease the amount of time and the
effort it takes to retrieve or to do
some kind of operation that is a
technical definition of what we mean
when we say caching and this single
mechanism or this single technique is a
huge factor in a lot of high performance
applications so let's go through a
couple of examples and understand where
exactly people use caching and how does
it exactly impact the performance of the
application and how important it is and
to give you a hint it is very important
at least when it comes to high
performance applications which track
latency in two digit micros or
milliseconds okay let's take the example
of Google pretty much all of us use or
have used Google search in our browsers
and what exactly happens when you search
some query in Google let's say you type
something in Google in the search bar
and you hit and enter and that query is
processed by Google search engine they
have a pretty complex algorithm and
workflow which every query goes through
that typically involves crawling
indexing and ranking billions and
billions of web pages and that whole
process is pretty expensive and when we
say expensive computer tionally
expensive right it takes a lot of
computing power a lot of CPU a lot of
memory resources and etc etc and let's
say a query like what is the weather
today and queries like these are
searched millions and millions of times
every day and without caching without
implementing this mechanism called
caching Google servers they would need
to recompute all the results for every
single query for every single query
involving the current weather of that
location and which will lead to a very
high latency and of course a very high
server load every single query would
require going through all the index
running all the ranking algorithms and
fetching the results which would in turn
significantly slow down the response STS
now when we insert caching in this so
what Google does the search engine is it
uses it a distributed in memory caching
system to store we'll see what is in
memory caching system soon but that's
how Google does it uses a distributed in
memory casing system distributed in the
sense the servers of the casing system
are spread across the whole world
they're not just concentrated in a
single location but they are spread
across all over the world and those cach
servers they store the results whatever
results are returned by all those
ranking algorithms and all those
different different algorithms that
are involved in the whole uh Google
search workflow they get cached or they
get stored in the servers and when a
user searches the system first checks
whether the results of that particular
query let's say you search the weather
in some city of India so the system
checks whether the results of that is
present in the cash or not if the query
is cached that means it is a cash hit
right that's that's what we call it's a
technical term whenever we find the data
that we are looking for the cash we call
it a cash hit if the system finds it it
Returns the results instantly right uh
retrieving data from a cache is very
fast that's the one of the reasons we
use cash in the first place right and
we'll see why exactly fetching data from
cash is fast as compared to our
traditional databases like disk based
databases right which is saw in the
previous video okay we'll soon get into
that well for now we are just going
through some examples to understand the
gravity or to understand the importance
of caching in different different
platforms and let's say the system does
not find the result right the query that
the user typed that has not been typed
before so the system the cache it does
not have the data so what it does it
goes through the normal workflow all the
ranking all the Sorting whatever
algorithms are involved and then it
takes that result and it caches it so
that the next time the same user of or
some other user tries to type the same
query then those results can be fetched
from the cach and can be returned to the
user okay that's one example taking
another example let say another popular
platform and we take Netflix how exactly
does Netflix a huge and a global
streaming platform which delivers
different different kinds of content
like movies series and animes etc etc
how does it deliver the content to
millions of users all over the world and
it steams large and when we say large it
can be multiple terabytes because the
way these streaming platforms work is
for a single video let's say for a
single movie it stores different
different resolutions let's say we have
a movie called movie one then
it goes through a process called
encoding and It prepares different
different resolutions for different
different devices and different
different network speeds so for a high
level explanation let's say it has a
1080p uh resolution and another for 720p
another for 480p etc etc right and
depending on your network speed and
depending on which device you're trying
to access the content of Netflix it
dynamically sends an optimiz version of
that content for or that movie right so
that you don't waste your bandwidth and
the load gets decreased on the Netflix
server also okay that's all about the
encoding part but talking about how does
it exactly sense or delivers hundreds
and thousands of terabytes of data to
millions of users spread across all over
the world right since Netflix is a
global streaming platform and that too
with minimal amount of buffering and and
decreasing server load so that Netflix
server don't crash and the way it does
is it uses something called CDN and CDN
also known as content delivery Network
the way they work is Netflix has its own
servers its own originating servers
let's say it's somewhere in the US right
in us there is a there are different
different data centers and different
different locations where it has its own
servers right and its own server racks
which store the actual movies right here
we have the actual movies but what it
does it goes an extra mile and what it
does we have our world here let's
imagine this is our whole world so at
different different locations different
different locations all over the world
and those locations are of course chosen
by the infrastructure that is available
and how much network connectivity etc
etc and a lot of parameters so all over
the world there are different different
locations and these are called Edge
locations Edge locations Edge right
these are called Edge locations because
these servers are strategically placed
so that the latency of the users
Connection in that region let's say
there is a server in this part of the
world then for this reason the latency
the latency of data or whatever requests
are served from the server is going to
be minimal right let's say we have us
somewhere here minimal as compared to
all the requests going through the
originating server which is situated in
us and that part of the data center
serving request from all over the world
then that will be a situation where all
the people who are in us they will have
low buffering time because
geographically speaking they are closer
to the servers that are serving the
content so of course their uh lat is
going to be very less as compared to
people from the other side of the world
right let's say from India and that is
the reason this is a strategy that a lot
of companies use right not just Netflix
CDN or content delivery networks are
very common and a lot of companies and
lot of small and big companies use them
to efficiently deliver different
different content it can be video files
it can be images it can be also web web
pages right web pages which consist of
static asss like JavaScript HTML or css
ET etc those kinds of assets are also
served from different different CDN when
you use a platform like versel they also
have an edge Network like this and their
servers are also spread across all of
the world so when you make a request to
a server to a front end app which is
deployed in versal so depending on your
location that request is served from the
closest region oral server to you
instead of going to the originating
server right so CDN are very common and
this is how Netflix the global streaming
platform serves billions and billions of
users with hundreds and thousands of
datab sub data every single minute using
this concept called caching the content
at Edge locations right we again come to
this concept called caching if you
remember the definition of is called
taking a subset of a primary storage and
placing it in a way that accessing data
from this source is much much faster
than accessing data from the primary
storage so taking the example of Netflix
Netflix takes some data a subset of the
data of course it does not cache all the
data of the Netflix storage in all the
edge locations that would incur a lot of
cost and of course a lot of resources is
also it they use a lot of algorithms
machine learning algorithms depending on
what type of content people of that
region are watching right they do a lot
of trend analysis and lot of real time
data Etc ET right a lot of computation
goes behind deciding what data what
subset of the data to cach so that the
amount of time and the
effort can be decreased to access that
data right you cannot just put
everything in cash right that defeats
the whole purpose and caching is also
more expensive than storing the data in
secondary storage or disk based storage
and that is the reason we don't put
everything in cash memory right dis
storages are relatively cheaper and also
offer a lot of capacity now moving on to
a third example let's take a platform
called X or also previously known as
Twitter okay and for this you can take
any social media examples so this
example can be applicable to Facebook
also and you can say LinkedIn or YouTube
videos etc etc right the same all these
social media platforms implement the
same kind of strategy for let's say if
you're familiar with how Twitter the
platform Works Twitter has a section
called trending topics right and what
Twitter does or what x does is it
identifies trending Topics by analyzing
millions and millions of Tweets in real
time it analyzes all the tweets that
people are making all over the world and
it extracts some kind of patterns and
some kind of Trends and it calculates
and that calculation is very expensive
it takes a lot of uh machine learning
based algorithms it takes a lot of gpus
and a lot of infrastructure right and it
also involves processing a large amount
of data terabytes and terabytes of data
because we are talking about about
analyzing tweets of people millions and
billions of people all over the world so
that is the reason to avoid doing this
computation of this large amount of data
and to use this much amount of resources
to avoid doing that again and again
because every time let's imagine if
Twitter did all this calculation every
time some user went to the trending
section of the then of course the server
will crash in minutes or seconds because
there are like billions of people and
if even half of them are trying to
access the trending section and every
user triggers this calculation this
expensive calculation of course the
server cannot handle that and they will
crash so what Twitter does of course to
avoid doing this computation this heavy
computation for each request it cashes
it okay and by now you can see the
pattern right every time there is a
situation where it's either about doing
a lot of heavy
computation or heavy amount of data when
we have situations like this when we
want to avoid doing a lot of computation
again and again and when we want to
avoid sending large amounts of data to a
lot of users these are the two scenarios
the common two scenarios when caching
comes into play right so coming back to
the Twitter example Twitter caches all
these trending topics because for a
trend to change in a particular region
right let's say you are in some country
and that country has ongoing elections
so elections being the trending topic in
Twitter is not something which is
subject to change in let's say seconds
or minutes right at least it will stay
in trending section for a couple of
hours or a couple of days and that is
the reason since it is not dynamically
changed it is not subject to minutes and
hours of change that that is the reason
it is very safe to cach the trending
section of Twitter so what Twitter does
it takes all this data all this millions
and billions of tweets and every few
minutes so we of course we cannot know
what is the exact algorithm or what is
the exact duration that Twitter does all
this computation or what computations
exactly Twitter does but taking a rough
estimation for the sake of this example
every few minutes every few minutes
Twitter takes all these data from
different different regions and it
executes different different algorithms
okay on a very high level speaking
different different machine learning
algorithms and Trend detection
algorithms and a lot of those
complicated stuff and it stores them in
a inmemory cash something like that is
we'll see what are some famous and
popular in memory cache Technologies but
red is is one of them and it is very
famous so let's imagine
calculates all these trending topics and
it stores it in an inmemory key Value
Store based database like redis and when
the users request it then it takes that
data from the cache instead of computing
all of that again it takes that data
from the cache and sends the user and
that is the reason the moment you open
your phone you get that data instantly
you do not see any kind of delay right
you do not see any kind of significant
loading time of course if you have a
very bad internet connection you'll see
loaders and all but if you have a
generally fast internet connection it's
pretty fast the whole UI interaction and
with those three examples we kind of
have a pattern here that every time we
want to avoid doing some kind of heavy
computation or some kind of heavy data
when we want to avoid these two kinds of
situation we resort to what we call as
caching and now that we know caching is
an important concept and it is is
implemented everywhere so on a high
level and since we want to limit the
context to especially backend
engineering something all the concepts
that you as a backend engineer are going
to deal with on your day-to-day life or
on your day-to-day development because
of that we want to limit the context of
caching because if you go around and
start to find the use the implementation
of caching in different different
context starting from Hardware to
Software to browsers etc etc it's going
to take a lot of time and of course it
is very good to have that knowledge but
it is very difficult to cover all of
that in a single video so we'll keep it
relevant on a high level when we talk
about caching you will see three levels
of caching at least you'll notice these
three caching more frequently as
compared to other kinds of caching as a
backend engineer those three are first
is Network level second hardware and
third is software based it's not purely
software based of course software based
caching also uses Hardware based caching
to provide the performance but it's
called software based caching because of
the interaction and because of the the
means of interaction you'll be dealing
with some kind of Library some kind of
software to interact with this cash
that's why it's called software based
caching but it's of course not purely
software based caching it is it works
with the hardware based cache okay now
going into each of that let's start with
network cache so inside Network cache
also there are different different use
cases a lot of use cases of caching but
the two major ones that you'll see
frequently are the first one is CDN as I
just explained in the Netflix example
how Netflix serves and delivers all
these heavy terabytes and terabytes of
content to uses all of the world there
we discuss CDN briefly so here we'll go
a little more deep into CDN and the
second thing is DNS DNS is also
something we use a lot every day you
don't really notice the use but it is
happening right and caching is also a
very important part when it comes to DNS
quaring so let's explore these two
things which fall under Network level
caches so first one is CDM also known as
content delivery Network the whole idea
of CDN or content delivery networks are
to Cache content on servers that are
geographically as I said geographically
closer to the end users that's why they
are also called Edge nodes or Edge
servers or Edge Computing any kind of
edge word that you notice that basically
means it is happening in a server that
is closest to you instead of a single
server or single servers in a particular
region or the originating server right
the CDN make use of this concept that
the content will be stored they will be
cached and served from the servers that
are closest to the users to minimize the
amount of latency and minimize the
amount of computation or the amount of
resources of the originating server now
on a high level this is how CDN work so
let's imagine a user makes a request and
it requests for some kind of resource a
resource like an image or a video or a
web page right some kind of resource by
entering a URL in the browser okay
that's how we typically access some kind
of data over the internet right through
the URL of our browser and that browser
that browser sends a DNS query to
resolve the domain name whatever the
domain name that we have typed of that
image of that video or that web page the
browser sends a DNS query to resolve
that domain name into an IP address
because that's the use case of DNS right
DNS names take domain names and convert
them into IP addresses so that our
browsers can access the actual location
of the server right now next what
happens the CDN domain name system the
CDN DNS system routes that particular
request to the nearest po po is also
called as point of presence and it is
just a fancy term it just basically
means a particular region where there
are multiple Edge servers these servers
that we are seeing here there are
multiple Edge servers in a particular
region and that concentrated region is
called po or point of presence for that
region right PO is just a collection of
multiple Edge servers for a particular
region now what happens the CDN DNS
system it routes the request to the
nearest po right the nearest region
which has multiple Edge servers so that
it can serve the content right so that
is the responsibility of the DNS system
because that's why DNS is a very
important component when it comes to CDN
and it routes the request depending on
multiple parameters parameters like
users geographic location right and the
network conditions what whether the user
has a stable internet connection or it
has a bad internet connection if it has
a bad internet connection depending on
that it might route to a different po or
different Edge server so because this
Edge server may only have the content of
the highest quality let's say you have a
banned internet connection and this
particular po or point of presence this
only has 1 1080 pixel formats of the
video right this is just a rough example
so depending on your network condition
the DNS system the the CDN DNS system it
will check that since you have a batter
internet connection it will route it to
a pop which has videos of lesser
qualities so that you can load that
resource with minimum amount of
buffering okay for example if a user in
New York requests a particular resource
an image or video or web page the CDN
the CDN system will direct the request
to your poop near New York right that's
how the requests are routed to the
nearest po using DNS next what happens
the Ed server once it reaches the PO
which basically means a collection of Ed
servers now here what happens it checks
if the requested content that particular
video that particular web page or image
or whatever that is whether it is in the
cach or not if if it is already cached
or not depending on that it is either a
cash hit or a cash M so as I already
said if whatever we are looking for if
it's already in the cash then we call it
a cash hit if it's not then it's called
a cash Miss if it is a cashit it finds
the resource and it just sends the
request to the user right it is the
happy path but if it is a cash Miss what
happens the content is not in the cache
so the edge server whatever Edge server
that is handling this particular request
it fetches it from the originating
server let's say the originating server
are somewhere in us right and the user
is in India so it is the responsibility
of that as server to fetch it from the
US servers the originating server where
the actual resource is present of course
the cash also has the copy of the
resource it is not a fake resource but
all the resources basically we are
talking about originating servers have
all the resources so that CDN can fetch
from them and serve users the content
and that's how typically a CDN a Content
delivery Network Works using DNS and
point of presence and originating
servers and all these buzzwords CDs also
use a concept called TTL time to live
right so depending on that they decide
how long to keep a particular piece of
content so usually companies decide some
kind of fair duration right this content
should only be cached for the next few
hours because after that it might have a
new version or there might be Regional
changes etc etc right so it is a safe
default so that after this amount of
time if a new request comes then instead
of serving the old content it fetches
from the originating server takes the
fresh content and serves it with a new
TTL time to right the way typical CDN
workflow works and it is considered as a
network level cache the Second Use case
of caching when it comes to network
layer is DNS DNS queries it they also
make heavy uses of caching to minimize
the latency of all the DNS queries that
are happening from billions and billions
of users at the same time so let's
imagine another user scenario so that
it's easier to keep track of how DNS
actually works and where exactly does it
actually implement the caching workflow
so let's imagine a user enters something
in the URL let's say a domain name
example.com right in their browser and
they press enter what happens the first
thing on we are just only focusing on
the DNS part of course when you type
something in your url bar a lot of
things happen but we'll be focusing on
just the DNS part right so the users
divides so after you hit enter the users
device whatever the device it is the
laptop or the smartphone it sends a DNS
query and it sends it to a recursive
resolver it's a technical term we'll see
what it means it sends the DNS query to
a recursive resolver and this
resolver is typically provided by the
users ISP ISP basically means whatever
company it is you are taking your
internet connection from so if you're
from India it could be Gio it could be
act or it could be AEL right so that is
your ISP now this resolver this
recursive resolver this is provided by
your ISP your internet service provided
or it could also be provided by some
third partyy DNS providers like Google
has a public DNS provider or Cloud flare
also as a public public DNS provider etc
etc right so it can be either of that it
can be your ISP or it can be a public
DNS provider like Google or Cloud flare
now second thing what happens the DNS
query is routed to your recursive
resolver which can be in your ISP or a
public DNS Server Like Google or Cloud
flare it does not matter we'll see what
exactly happens once the query reaches
the recursive resolver the recursive
resolver it does the following steps
first thing what it does it first checks
the local cache to see if it already has
that particular IP right some random IP
it checks once it has the query it
checks whether it already has that
particular IP cached in its local system
when you say local it means without
accessing a remote storage or anything
like that in its local uh primary
storage or secondary storage dis based
stage whatever right in its own system
it checks whether it has the entry for
this IP in its local cach or not
depending on that either it is a cash
hit or a cash Miss if it is a cash hit
the resolver immediately Returns the
result and what is the result in this
case we the DNS query was to check what
is the IP of example.com so it checks
whether example.com is in its local cach
or not if it does then finds the
corresponding IP address add and it
returns it to the user to our browser or
to our smartphone whatever it is right
but if it is a Miss if it did not find
it in its local cache it sends that
query to other resols what are these
other resols we proceed to the third
step here right if it does not have the
result if it if it does not have the
corresponding IP address for that
particular domain example.com it misses
it here it is a cash Miss and it queries
other resolvers and it is called quering
the root server okay there are a lot of
root servers I think 13 or 14 I don't
know the exact figure but these are
called root servers okay there are
multiple root servers spread all over
the world and they don't necessarily
have the particular IP then they don't
have the result for what is the IP
address of example.com but what they do
have is they have the address of the top
level domains right top level domains
like
doco Doin etc etc they have the
addresses or referrals for these top
level domains or these top level domain
servers okay we are talking about other
servers now now since it is example.com
it sends the address or the reference of
the Doom top level server next you
proceed it reaches the top level server
for Doom okay the TLD TLD for the do top
level domain right and from there that
also does not have the IP address of
example.com of course then this sends
the address for the authoritative called
authoritative name server for
[Music]
example.com it has the address for the
authoritative name server for
example.com
and it sends the address of that then
what happens the recursive resolver
right we are still talking about the
recursive resolver which has the
responsibility of finding the IP address
of this particular domain name and it is
called recursive because it goes deep
and deep and deep into different
different servers until it finds the IP
address that's why it's called a
recursive resolver okay and at last we
reach the actual authoritative name
server for example.com and from there we
can take the IP address whatever IP
address it is can take that and it
returns it where exactly caching comes
into play here DNS heavily depends on
caching because of how much of work it
is to recursively reach out to different
different servers and finally get the IP
that's the reason DNS heavily depends on
caches so that it does not have to do
all this work for every single request
so that it has some kind of local cash
which it can use for further request it
only wants to do it once for a certain
amount of time right so most operating
systems it can be Windows or Mac or
Linux maintain some kind of local cach
for DNS okay and when a user request a
particular domain the OS the operating
system checks its local cash first okay
before it goes to your ISP the recursive
resolver etc etc it checks its local
cache if it can find it then it skips
going to the query resolver the
recursive resolver and immediately finds
the IP address and goes to that and
whatever the normal browser flow is then
the next level if it does not find the
entry for that particular domain then
the next level of cach is browsers of
course
browsers most of the modern web browsers
like Chrome Firefox they maintain their
own DNS cache okay after our operating
system the next hierarchy the next level
of caching is implemented by our
browsers they have their own local cach
or DNS so that if our operating system
cannot provide the corresponding IP
address browsers also try to maintain
their own cash they check if they have
the IP address of a particular domain
from some previous request if it does
then they can skip going to the
recursive query resolver and they can
imediately access the website that's the
next level the next level of cash is
from the resolver the the recursive
resolver that we talked about which
recursively tries to find the IP address
until it finds it in some server whether
it is the root server the authoritative
name server or whatever right that
recursive resolver which is provided
either provided by ISP or something like
Google public DNS or Cloud flare right
these components they which are known as
recursive resolvers they also maintain
their own cash so that if for some
request they can find the corresponding
entry they can immediately return it so
that they can skip going to all these
different different servers to find the
IP address and beyond that also when we
talked about authoritative name servers
they also have some kind of cache not
all of them implemented but some of them
do and using which they can also skip
going to skip making further request to
further servers right so as you can see
DNS also implements caching heavily in
multiple layers next we have is the
hardware level caching so if you are
from a computer science background You'
be already familiar with all these
Concepts what is L1 cache what is L2
cache L3 cache what is main memory what
is hard dis etc etc so caching is also
implemented at Hardware level to make
computations faster and to make a lot of
CPU level operations faster so on a high
level without going into too much
technical side of it you can see that we
have here our CPU chips which do the
actual processing then we have multiple
layers of caches we have the L1 cach
here and the L2 cache and we also have
the L3 cache which is a memory unit
which is shared between different
different caches right this memory is
shared between different different CPU
units then we have the Ram or random
access memory which is also called as
the main memory and then we have the
secondary storage hard disk and Network
CS Etc ET so what exactly happens CPU
keeps these memory units also called as
L1 cach L2 cach and L3 cache so that it
can cast some of the repeated
computations or some data which are
frequently used or which are going to be
used say to give an example if you are
familiar with the concepts of arrays the
reason arrays are a very good data
structures for sequential accesses
whenever you start traversing the
elements of the array from a particular
direction let's say you have 1 2 3 4 5
here the moment you start traving here
CPUs or different different Computing
units inside your processing units what
they do through different predictive
algorithms they take the entire memory
unit and they put it in some cache right
can be L one cach L2 cach depending on
the predictive algorithm and that's the
reason accessing elements sequencially
in an array is a very fast operation
because of predictive algorithms of the
processing unit that is just one
examples of how harder level cach works
the thing that we want to focus here is
this part the random access memory or
the main memory it's considered and
whenever we talk about major caching
Technologies say redis or M cached these
are called inmemory key Value Store
based databases
and they are called inmemory databases
because they store data in your main
memory or the random access memory and
it is called Random Access Memory
because compared to hard dis or ssds in
which you can access the data in a
mechanical way so if we take hard dis
for example there is some kind of head
which revolves around the dis and it
finally finds the data it it is a
mechanical operation and compared to
that main memory or Random Access Memory
it has a bunch of capacitors and all and
through the use of electrical signals
and with the direct access of different
different parts of the memory addresses
through their addresses it can directly
access the data with a single electrical
signal and that is the reason it is
called random access memory which means
it does not matter from what direction
you try to access the data the speed and
the time is going to be the
almost constant that's why it's called a
random access memory and it is very fast
to access data from this part of the
memory but the problem is we don't have
random access memory or the main memory
in abundance even though we have speed
at our disposal when it comes to Random
Access Memory they have limited capacity
and also they are volatile in nature
which means whenever you turn off your
power whatever whatever data is stored
in random access memory it goes away
right it clears it start fresh whenever
you start your computer right because of
their volatile nature and because of the
way they are created at least from the
harder level they are created with the
tradeoffs that we are trading of
nonvolatility and capacity for Speed
right so that's the reason we cannot
completely replace a hard disk or our
traditional disk based St with random
access memory right they have their use
they are fast when it comes to data
access and data retrieval but they are
not a replacement for our secondary
storage okay storing data in secondary
storage is permanent permanent permanent
in the sense they are not volatile does
not matter whether your program is
accessing it or not whether your
computer is on or not the data persists
there because it is physically writing
the data in the disk right that is the
reason hard disk or second disc storage
have their use and primary storages have
their own use primary storage have very
fast data access time and secondary
storages have slower data access but
they provide the safety of persistence
and that is the reason Technologies like
redis or mcast these databases they make
use of this random access memory or the
main memory to store their data and
behind the scenes for persistence they
make use of the secondary storage so
with some kind of mechanism when the
program starts off they take the data
from the secondary storage and load it
in the main memory again so that you
have your data
persistence but when you retrieve it you
retrieve it from the primary memory
right is the responsibilities of these
programs that is M cach or whatever
caching technology the in memory caching
technology that you are using is there
responsibility to implement persistence
Etc with the secondary storage but when
we are talking about accessing the data
whether retrieving it or modifying it it
happens with the primary memory right
that's the reason data access operations
from these databases are very
fast and finally coming back to the
context of backend development
Technologies like redis or mcast or if
we are talking about Cloud Technologies
then Technologies like AWS elastic cache
these come into play they provide some
kind of storage and that storage is
based on the primary memory and that's
the reason data access operations are
very fast we call these
Technologies in memory key value based
no SQL databases right there are four
components here the first thing we
already saw they are called inmemory
based databases because they as compared
to traditional databases like Po gra or
MySQL they are not stored in diss right
second the storages they are stored in
Ram or primary storage that's the reason
they are very fast right that's why they
are called inmemory databases the second
thing is key value based as compared to
traditional databases relational
databases which have very strict schema
and you have to create tables and you
have to create rows etc etc right
instead of that here the data structures
are pretty simple you have keys and you
have values you have a particular key
and for that key you can store anything
it can be a list it can be a Json it can
be a string number ET different
different Technologies offer different
different data types so we won't go deep
into that you can do your own research
for that and that's the reason they are
called key value based no SQL databases
right they don't enforce the strictness
of traditional SQL databases and that's
about the name now since we are talking
about databases like this which we use
in our day-to-day backend development
there are two types of caching
strategies caching strategies the first
one is lazy caching or also known as
cash aside and the second one is known
as write through and surprisingly we
have already talked about this so we
won't go very deep into this all in all
lazy caching basically means let's say
there is a client and it is requesting
some
resource so that server checks whether
that resource is present in the cash not
if it is then it returns that resource
if it is not it fetches it from a
different storage right some kind of
primary storage and it fetches it it
gets the data it stores it in the cash
and then it Returns the result to the
client so that the next time the client
makes that request or some other client
makes that request it again checks and
it finds that in the cash and it returns
it that's why they are called lazy
caching you don't proactively cash
things by predicting from client
interaction or patents etc etc you just
cash it when someone actually requests
it that's why they're called lazy
caching and it is a pattern that is very
famous in a lot of different different
context in backend development the
second one is called Write through
caching it is more about the cash
updation strategy which basically means
every time something changes right every
time there is a post call or put call or
patch call where you are actually
changing some resource or creating some
resource in the database in your primary
storage what you do you make the change
for that resource in your database you
make the data as query at the same time
in the same API call in the same
execution flow you also make the same
change in your cache so that the next
time the request comes you can serve it
from the cash and which also means all
your operations all your right
operations bring more overhead because
at the same time you have to update the
database and the cache at the same time
time but the advantage here is your cash
is always fresh right it is never
expired you never serve old data since
you update the data in the database and
the cash at the same time your cash is
always fresh so those are two major
strategies that you will see frequently
in your day-to-day development the next
major component when we are talking
about Technologies like redis or MC is
the eviction policy something else that
we should be aware of is the eviction
policy and what it means is when you
have a cash as we already know that in
memory caches like redis they use
primary storage or the random access
memory which is limited in capacity as
compared to the secondary storage so it
is pretty obvious that at one point
we'll run out of memory or if we are
using a manage storage like a elastic
cash right so they have a storage limit
right in these conditions we are bound
to run out of memory at some point and
at that point we have to decide that we
want to delete data from our cache right
of course from the initial part of the
video we have already discussed that
cash is only a subset of the data which
is frequently accessed which is store in
a different location so that the
retrieval is fast right so the keyword
to focus here is a subset of the primary
storage right we cannot store all of the
primary storage to cash and that is the
reason we have to decide that at some
point we have to let go of some data so
that the new data can be stored new data
which are more important which have
higher priority than whatever the old
dat ties and that's why we have the
eviction policies eviction policies
basically means you decide how are you
getting rid of the old data so that new
data can be stored in the cach so a
couple of strategies are the first one
is no eviction and this basically means
you do not configure any eviction policy
the next time you try to insert data
into the cache you get some error that
the memory is full right does not make
any sense but if you have not configured
any eviction policies then the
configuration is called No eviction the
second one is lru also known as least
recently used this algorithm basically
checks that which pieces of data are
least recently used basically means if
there are other data points let's say we
have 1 2 3 4 four keys in the cache and
now the memory is full right and the
database or something like that is they
keep track of when was the last time a
particular key was accessed let's say
this key was accessed today and this is
also accessed today this is also
accessed today but this was accessed
yesterday now when a new data point
comes across let's say we want to store
Key five when five comes across and this
cash is full this has to make space for
five and in this situation if we have
configured least recently used eviction
policy what it does it checks which is
the data point which is the oldest
accessed data point and since four was
accessed yesterday and all the other
ones were accessed today only it selects
this that you will go out and five will
go in this is what we mean when we say
least recently used or lru cash eviction
policies third we also have lfu which
means least frequently used so going
back to the earlier example forget over
the time let's say okay we have four
Keys 1 2 3 4 and five comes across now
instead of tracking when was the last
time this key was accessed it also
tracks what is the frequency of the axis
let's say one was accessed five times
and we are talking about so far right
one the key number one was accessed five
times so far and two has been accessed
10 time then we have three six and four
was accessed let's say 23 times right
some random numbers now when five comes
across it checks which is the data point
is least frequently used which means the
access frequency is the least so if you
check this one the key one was was
accessed the least number of times right
the five the other time the other keys
are being accessed more frequently and
that is the reason it it selects one and
says that you will go out and five will
go in that's what we mean when we say
least frequently used cash eviction
policy then we also have TTL time to
live based eviction policy which
basically means in redis we can
configure what is the TDL time to live
for different different keys right so
depending on that a particular key can
be invalidated automatically depending
on the TTL time to okay and that can
also be part of the eviction policy so
in the same scenario when five comes in
it checks that which of these keys have
the lowest amount of TTL so which key is
going to be expired soon right depending
on that it selects that key and takes it
out and inserts the new key and that's
what we mean when we say time to leave
TTL based eviction policy and that's
pretty much all you need to know when it
comes to the technicality of in memory
caches like red and all rest of it is
pretty straightforward you take whatever
compatible library is available in your
corresponding programming language let's
say nodejs has node redis or something
something so depending on that you just
use the library it's not very complex
you provide a key you provide a value
you store it and you when you want to
retrieve it you provide the key and you
get the value right it is pretty
straightforward it has no complexities
like like SQL queries and aggregation
etc etc it's pretty simple to access
right but all this technical familiarity
with how the technology Works behind the
scenes what are the major components it
helps you make sense of the whole thing
and make better decisions etc etc so now
that we have discussed all the
technicalities of inmemory databases
like red is mcast let's see some
examples what are some use cases where
do we actually use Technologies like
redis the in memory databases and a
typical backend engineering workflow and
one of the major use cases is database
DB query so let's take an example that
you have an SQL query which has a lot of
joints and it tries to join a lot of
tables it does a lot of aggregation
right and finally it ends up with a few
rows it is a very compute intensive
operation because you have a large data
set let's say millions and millions of
rows and it is a very compute intensive
data set and you have through monitoring
you have noticed that this particular
API which calls this particular database
query it is hit pretty frequently right
it is let's say in your landing page or
in your dashboard page and a lot of
users are hitting this API and it is
putting a lot of load in your database
so what you can do you can take that
particular query in the next line what
you can do you can cach the result with
some detail time to live you can say
that for the next 1 hour cash this
result and when the next request comes
check if the result is present in the
cach then serve it from there otherwise
do the calculation once and store it in
the cache and whenever some other
modification happens you can manually
change the cache or you can delete it or
you can handle it accordingly right then
whenever users hit that particular API
instead of putting the load on the DB
you can directly serve that particular
uh result of the query from a cash right
that is a good example right whenever
you have a very compute intensive
database operation and it is it is being
called pretty frequently then you can
cach that result to save some Computing
time save some resource and to reduce
the latency of the API call also to take
some real world examples e-commerce
websites like Amazon they also cast
product details prices and inventory
data etc etc to avoid querying the
database for every single request so
imagine there is some sale going on for
a Macbook and all and if Amazon did not
cash the details of a Macbook for that
particular product then during the
period of the sale millions of users hit
that particular web page and the
fetching the image of the MacBook or
fetching all the product description of
the MacBook these are all database
operations right and the database will
get a million requests and that puts
significant load on the database and for
no reason because a information like
product details for a Macbook it does
not change very often right so it is a
very good candidate for caching so
that's the reason websites like Amazon
platforms like Amazon they cash static
data like product details prices in some
cases so that they can reduce the load
in the database and the database can
actually to do the important stuff
instead of serving the static content
like product details the same way social
media platforms say like Twitter or
Facebook they cach user profile data
user profile data is not something that
changes very often right maybe a couple
of times in a year right that's the
reason they serve they cach the user
profile data so that every time that
data is fetched that is served from the
cash instead of from the database
imagine if it is a social media profile
of some celebrity in that case that
particular page and that particular API
of patching the user profile details of
that celebrity that might get hit let's
say a thousand times per day right or if
they have an upcoming movie maybe a
million times a day in that case putting
all that load on the database does not
make much of a sense since that user
profile information is pretty static
most of the times it can serve that
content from cash right and even if the
user makes some change they can
invalidate the cach and put the new
entry but it is a pretty read heavy
operation as you can see from the
pattern and whenever we have a read
heavy operation and the right is pretty
infrequent we can make use of caching
okay so database caching database query
caching is one of the primary examples
of when we use Technologies like redis
or in memory databases the second one is
session storing session so if you have
watched the authentication video in this
playlist you might be aware of this in a
typical authentication flow after a
successful authentication a session
token is generated for that particular
user and that session token is stored in
some kind of storage right and ideally
it is stored in redis or a inmemory
database so that every time the user
makes a request or an API call we have
to fetch that session information from
somewhere right if did not use redis
we'll have to fetch that from our
database and as you already know
fetching data from random access memory
or primary memory or in this case cash
like redis is much much faster than
fetching data from a database and that's
the reason in order to avoid latency in
every single API and to avoid putting
load on our database people usually
store session tokens authentication
related session tokens in redis or any
in memory databases right that is
another use case is of redis third is
API caching so let's say in your back
end you are making use of some external
API let's say some weather AP and you
are taking the information from that and
you are doing some kind of computation
to serve your own front end now every
time your frontend makes a request to
your API if you do not make use of
caching you also make another request to
the weather API to fetch the weather
data and if you have a lot of users and
they are making multiple API calls to
here you also end up making a lot of and
thousands of API calls to this external
API and usually since external API calls
have some kind of limit some kind of
rate limit or some kind of pricing based
on how frequently are calling them you
will quickly increase your billing or
you'll hit your rate limit and since in
this case it is not realtime data right
it is a weather data which is safe to
Cache weather data does not not change
in like seconds or minutes that's why it
is a kind of data that is safe to Cache
so what you do you fetch that
information from that API you cash it
and you make use of that in all the
subsequent request that is coming from
your frontend and you can use something
like TTL for let's say of an hour so you
cach this data for an hour and for the
next 1 hour all the requests will use
the value of the weather data from the
cache and after an hour the cash
automatically invalidates it and the
next time a request comes instead of
taking it from cash you'll fetch the
weather data again you you'll put it in
the cash and then you return the request
right whenever it comes to interacting
with external API we think about caching
so that we can decrease the billing or
we can avoid hitting the rate limit and
one last use case that comes to mind is
since we are talking about rate limiting
rate limiting mechanism is also
implemented most of the times using a
technology like redis or any inmemory
caches because the way rate limiting is
implemented is it is usually some kind
of middleware which sits somewhere in
the middle since it is called a middle
that's the reason before the request is
passed to your whatever route or
controller or whatever it is and this is
the browser or any client that is making
the request and this is this is the
entry point to your particular server
right and this is the middleware the
rate limit middleware and what it does
is it takes the header some kind of
header which gives it the IP address of
the user usually the header is something
like X forwarded for right this header
is mostly used for implementing rate
limiting to find out the IP address the
public IP address of your client
wherever the request is coming from and
this is usually added by reverse process
like X or whatever that you are using
that is the point the point is the job
of this middleware the rate limit
middleware is it takes this header out
from that request every request has some
default headers Associated you already
know then it takes this particular
header out from that request and it
checks the IP address and usually rate
limits have some kind of default
mechanisms of durations like how many
requests let's say you can only make 50
requests per second right and these are
mostly implemented to avoid uses from
Bots let's say if it's a very compute
intensive API then rate limiting can
help you uh save your resource right
save your
compute let's say this is the condition
you a particular client can only do 50
request in 1 minute let's say 1 minute
then whenever a request comes it checks
that whatever value it is in the X
forwarded for header let's say it find
some IP 10 12 some kind of Ip since we
are talking about a key Value Store okay
it saves some kind of counter say that
this is the IP address for this IP
address for the start of this minute the
first request came I got one request the
next time the request comes it checks
the cash so far one minute has not
passed right that's why it checks and it
increases the counter from one it makes
two
same way 3 4 every time a request comes
it increases the counter so that within
a minute if the counter exceeds 50 then
what it does it blocks that request and
it sends an error response of 4 to9 and
when we send a status code of 4 to9 it
means too many requests too many
requests this is how a particular
workflow looks like for rate limiting
now coming into caching
this particular part where it stores the
counter is usually in redice or any
inmemory databases because in if it
stored it in a relational database
something like pogress or MySQL that is
possible of course that is possible it
has a persistent storage and we can
retrieve data etc etc but difference is
taking data out from a relational
database takes more time right even a
difference of let's say 20 or 30
milliseconds that makes a difference on
what is the latency of the API if we
stored it in a relational database then
for each request we'll be making a
database call in turn the first thing is
anyway the latency will be increased for
that particular API since we are making
a database call unnecessarily for each
request second thing is the load on our
database also increases let's say there
are like a th000 users then, users are
making 100 request per a minute then our
database will be flooded with just the
request of rate limiting right that is
the reason we want to separate this out
for two reasons first is of course to
make it as fast as possible so that we
can minimize the latency of apis and
also to decrease the database load and
that is the reason whenever we are
talking about implementing rate limiting
we make use of inmemory databases like
redis instead of storing it in our
relational databases and with that we
have pretty much covered what is caching
why do we use it some real world
examples and why do we use inmemory
caches why is it called inmemory cache
why Ram primary storage is faster and
some real world examples of redis some
different components of redis ET ET and
that pretty much covers all you need to
know to be comfortable with caching to
understand caching to understand the
context where it is used and what are
the different components of it and why
do we use it some real we
examples and next you can use all these
Technologies you can start with red is
the open source alternative V key right
and you can depending on your
programming language you can install a
library and you can get your hand study
and see what are the differences in
accessing data from a relational
database as compared to something like
in memory database like redis